sometimes it can get a little
cringe-worthy Kris Jenner reveals the
one thing she'd change about those early
keeping up with the kardashians days
Haley pretty sexual the famous momager
stop by The Late Late Show with James
Corden on Tuesday to promote season 17
of the family's reality show and
admitted that after all these years only
one thing embarrasses her looking back
the outfits right I think in the hair
and stuff like that I don't think like
it sometimes it can get a little
cringe-worthy but I think that
everything we look back on is such a
great lesson and taught us so much and
we're here because of the journey we've
been on so I'm just grateful we think
these are the looks Kris is talking
about and when asked if there was a
moment she wishes she could change in
the history of Keeping Up she had this
to say oh my goodness how long have we
got yeah yeah I don't you know I don't
think I would change a thing
I think it got us to here and that's a
blessing ét caught up with Kris in May
and she dished on what fans could expect
from season 17 it's really exciting
we're now we're on to shooting season 17
so you'll see that but I think the rest
of the season has so many crazy things
going on and as I say every time you
guys ask it's just tune in because you
never know what's gonna happen and when
et chatted with Kim in April she opened
up about why the family puts all the
crazy out there for the world to see do
you ever have the conversation of this
is too far we're not going to film this
yeah I think we battle that all the time
but we've filmed everything from
deliveries to marriages divorces and our
motto is like we just thought we all
film and we just sit on it you know by
the time editing happens
and you know the show comes out so many
different stories have been made up that
other people have kind of made up about
our lives we committed to this at the
beginning which was almost 12 years ago
and we you know have always stayed true
to who we are and always shared pretty
much everything so that's just who we've
been and I don't you know I think
there's like something really courageous
in that I think one of the things that
has made the success of the show is that
we are you know show those
vulnerabilities and we're also
transparent and you do see how it
actually unfolded and what happened
because everybody thinks they know the
whole story and they don't so I think
that's the interesting thing is just
watching how we all handle you know
these situations and and what we all
learn from it